[Music]
on this monday night canada's
first shots
the country's mass vaccination effort is
underway
less than a year ago no one believed it
would be possible to get this vaccine
out
who is getting the first doses plus new
details on how the complex plan
will unfold there are so many moving
parts in
this process and how soon could a second
vaccine be approved
the critical message to albertans they
see the vaccine getting started
and so people erroneously think this
is going to be over quickly and the
meaning of this moment of hope
near the end of a devastating year
global national with donna friesen
finally a moment to celebrate after an
agonizing
year this woman a personal support
worker at a toronto nursing home
who has worked countless double shifts
is among the first canadians to get a
covid19 vaccine
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is happening the first doses of the
pfizer biontech vaccine have been
delivered and canada's
mass immunization campaign is underway
the first shots were given in ontario
and quebec
30 000 doses are expected to arrive at
14
sites in all 10 provinces by the end of
this week
some are calling today v-day and canada
isn't the only country celebrating
vaccinations also began
in the u.s today one of the first people
to receive one was critical care nurse
sandra lindsey she works in a new york
city hospital
icu i feel hopeful today
i'm relieved
i feel like healing is coming i want to
instill public confidence that the
vaccine
is safe we're in a pandemic and so we
all need to do our parts to put an
end to the pandemic
in both the u.s and canada the plan is
to roll out the vaccine to the general
public early next year
for now with supplies limited doses are
being reserved for people considered the
highest priority
eric sorenson begins our vaccine
coverage tonight
it's reminiscent of emergency air
supplies to the developing world
only it's canada the resources of
government science and logistics being
brought to modern day disaster relief
the first needles prepared at toronto's
university health network
specific location withheld for security
reasons
the first recipients from the rakai
non-profit long-term care center
front-line workers who battled outbreaks
and death at their facility
anita kidanian for 30 years a personal
support worker and among the first in
the country to get a kovit 19
shot how did it feel i'm okay i'm
excited
yeah why because i'm the first one to
have the vaccine for more care workers
who like so many canadians risked their
safety
also now getting protection we have been
waiting for this for so long
and i'm i'm here now and i'm so thankful
it's an historic moment in a pandemic
that has sickened and killed
thousands in this country today really
we turn the corner
but you know i like to say this is the
shot that will be heard around the world
literally and we're going to really
start
conquering this illness thanks to you
the pfizer biontech vaccine the first of
several that canada has
contracts to receive requires ultra-cold
refrigeration
they're going to 14 centers equipped
with special freezers in all 10
provinces
the first thirty thousand doses being
divided up this week
represent just a fraction of one percent
of what will be needed in the months
ahead
but less than one year after covet 19
swept into canada
ontario's premier was there to witness
the arrival of medicine
that it's hoped will return the country
back to normal make no mistake
there's a long road ahead of us but what
this represents
is hope and proof that this pandemic
will come to an end experts insist there
have been no
shortcuts on safety the speed is the
result of
a singular focus of the entirety of
civilization on one problem
and when money is no object magical
things could happen
and so the first publicized needles also
kick off an effort to reassure canadians
the vaccine is safe
the boss at the rakai center said she
was challenged by her staff
if you get it then i will get it so i'm
here i'm taking it for the team
we're doing this not only ourselves but
mostly for our residents and their
families
so that they have faith in us canada has
contracts for so many vaccines that it
could potentially receive enough not
only for all canadians
but ultimately enough to share with
other parts of the world
eric sorensen global news toronto
vaccinations also began today in quebec
where the first doses went to long-term
care homes
the pfizer biontech vaccine needs to be
kept ultra
cold and in many jurisdictions it's been
deemed too complex to move beyond
vaccination sites inside hospitals but
quebec overcame that
and as mike armstrong reports some of
the most vulnerable quebecers
are now the first to be protected
this was the first vaccination in quebec
89 year old giselle levesque didn't bat
an eyelash
when it was over she simply asked the
nurse if it went well
and was told it had followed by this
[Applause]
moment
quebec's first shipments of pfizer
biontech vaccine went to two long-term
care facilities
one in quebec city where levesque was
vaccinated and this one in montreal
yeah first stop at the maimonides
geriatric center was
gloria la luz the 78 year old has lost
eight friends to covet 19. she's been so
scared she hasn't left her room in
months
getting the shot she says couldn't have
been easier and
couldn't have been more important
everybody has to get a vaccination
it's the only way we're going to be able
to live quebec took delivery of five
boxes of vaccine enough for about 2500
people
now where most provinces are setting up
vaccination centers and will move people
to those sites
quebec is trying to go another way it's
prioritized the most vulnerable
seniors in long-term care facilities so
it's sending the first batches there
parallel to vaccinating residents
they're also going to be vaccinating
health care workers but pfizer biontec
doesn't allow the vaccine to be moved so
once the doses are in the freezers at
long-term care facilities
that's it they have to come here until
the last
dose they have to come here
[Music]
quebec is hoping once pfizer biontech
sees the process
can be moved around it may loosen some
of the rules
i think with the time over the next few
days they'll see
that we can back side vaccine properly
now as this good news drops in quebec
there may be some rough news
coming the premier is set to announce a
lockdown tuesday effective
after christmas it would include the
closure of businesses deemed
non-essential
and extending the holiday breaks for
schools
mike armstrong global news montreal
this is just the beginning of a long and
complex rollout that is intended to
reach every person in the country
it involves everything from shipping
specialized freezers to developing smart
communication strategies
to convince hesitant canadians to roll
up their sleeves
david aiken reports on what we know
about those plans
there are so many moving parts in this
process of the largest mass vaccination
that our country has seen vaccines are
ottawa's top priority so public services
minister anita anand
gets on the phone herself with pfizer's
ceo
to make sure canada gets its share of
doses
i said thirty thousand this week i did
not say thirty thousand next week i said
a similar shipment i'm trying to confirm
that number for next week and while
anand haggles with pfizer
she also has to find somewhere to put
the vaccine when it gets
here to that end her department is
buying up freezers
by the dozen orders have been placed for
more than 400
including the ultra cold models that can
store the pfizer biontech vaccine at
minus 70 degrees celsius 42 freezers
have been delivered so far and
they've been shipped to various
locations around the country
next up a communications campaign to
ensure canadians that
the vaccine is safe it's a campaign
experts say is overdue
it's time to start leveraging
pre-existing networks and and really
speaking with community leaders that
represent various communities throughout
the country
to really ensure that people have access
to the best information
so that they can help make informed
decisions when vaccines become available
and it's not going to be easy but it's
certainly something that has to be done
canadian security agencies are already
fighting online disinformation campaigns
more than 3 600 fake government websites
trying to pass on incorrect or
misleading health information
have been taken down according to the
defense minister first
thing that was concerning to us is the
disinformation
that that's out there we need to be able
to counter that meanwhile health canada
officials are working overtime to
approve the next likely vaccine
from moderna and hope to give it the
green light by year end
david aiken global news ottawa
in alberta there's no sign the spread of
the virus is slowing
nearly 2 000 new cases were reported
there today a new daily record
and 15 more albertans died from the
virus the province has received its
first shipment of the pfizer biontech
vaccine
hundred doses in the province says it
expects more than twenty five thousand
to arrive
next week the first shots will go to
health care workers in calgary and
edmonton
hospitals and icu's in much of alberta
are full
tougher public health restrictions are
now in place in that province
but it's going to take time to see the
impact and getting some people to comply
could be a battle in itself
heather eurix west reports
he's become known as mr covet a funny if
not nightmarish take on the virus that
has changed
all of our lives our goal is to get
people's attention
to help them see common situations from
a different perspective
and as a result to influence their
behavior
dr hinshaw says she knows some people
are now tuning out her daily updates
and even though the ads rely on humor
there is nothing funny about the
situation at hand
i think people are tired of the pandemic
i think that they see the vaccine
getting started and so i think
people erroneously think that this is
going to be over quickly
and unfortunately it's not and it makes
me sad to think of all the lives that
are going to be lost
the number of covid patients now
flooding into alberta's hospital awards
could soon put the entire health system
in jeopardy
so getting people to comply with current
public health orders has never been so
important yet every saturday without
fail alberta's major cities have seen
rallies protesting the measures aimed at
keeping people safe
on monday calgary city council voted to
increase penalties
for people who refuse to comply at this
point everybody's got a mask everybody
knows the rules
and so if you're not wearing your mask
it's not by mistake fines generally
don't work
positive things do work this university
of alberta psychiatry professor says
behavioral science research is pretty
clear
if you want people to change what
they're doing you have to use a
combination of carrots and sticks
restrictions need to come with rewards
so
how can you reward people for not
gathering how can you reward people for
wearing masks in public
i'm sure people come up with creative
ways of doing that
offering safe alternatives is important
too montreal is making outdoor spaces
more appealing while calgary has
outfitted its parks with temporary fire
pits
providing some warmth through the cold
months ahead if we're going to be
successful
we need a number of tools and they all
need to be aligned together for this to
succeed otherwise i am very fearful
about what will happen in january and
february in this country
the new year positioned to become the
pandemic's deadliest period
unless the behavior of many changes fast
heather urex west global news
calgary the saskatchewan government is
tightening public health restrictions
for the holiday season
and extending them until january 15th
starting thursday all private indoor
gatherings will be limited to immediate
members of your household with some
exceptions
outdoor gatherings will be restricted to
10 people bingo halls and casinos must
close on saturday and personal care
services like hair salons must cut their
capacity in half
effective christmas day retail stores in
saskatchewan must do the same and large
retailers will be restricted
to 25 percent capacity a new strain of
covid19 could be spreading in the uk
health officials say there is no
evidence it is any more dangerous but
it may be spreading faster more than a
thousand cases have been identified
most in southern england parts of the
region including london
will face tougher restrictions starting
on wednesday
available to all coming up the lofty
goal of making the vaccine accessible to
everyone in the u.s
the world's worst hit nation
a pivotal moment in the u.s today as the
first covit 19 vaccines were given there
with the prick of a needle the worst hit
country in the world was given a dose of
hope
an icu nurse in new york was among the
first to get the pfizer biontech vaccine
new york's governor calls it the weapon
that will end the war
more than three hundred thousand
americans have already died from covid19
and thousands more are dying every day
vaccines won't stop that immediately of
course but as jackson proskow reports
today
does mark the beginning of the end
those on the front lines are now first
in line for the vaccine
the hardest part by far has been
watching people die alone
in ohio health care workers were
vaccinated on mass
we need to trust the physicians and
trust the scientists that that's why i
volunteered to do this
in new york nurse sandra lindsay became
the first person in her state to be
inoculated
i hope this march will begin into the
end of a very
painful time in our history but it is
just the beginning
an unprecedented effort is now underway
to manufacture
and ship tens of millions of doses in
the u.s
fedex and ups have been tasked with
delivering to every state
the precious cargo moves under guard of
u.s marshals
it's going to be hard to imagine this
going off without a hitch that there
likely are unanticipated issues that are
going to arise when you're shipping that
many vaccine doses all around the
country
the hope is that up to six different
vaccines will be available on a
widespread basis by late spring
enough for every american who wants it
by the end of the month of may or the
middle of the month of june
we would have produced enough vaccines
doses to
immunize the totality of the american
population
to get there the u.s will have to get
through the worst days of the pandemic
the cdc estimates two to three thousand
deaths per day
for the next two to three months models
suggest the u.s
is on track to record 500 000 deaths by
april first
what do people need to keep in mind over
the next few months
well that number one the vaccine is not
going to appreciably impact
our lived reality right now this is the
worst of it
and and so people really need to keep
their eye on the prize vigilance
practicing everything we've been talking
about
no travel absolutely none that means
that while an end is in sight it's not
here yet
but increasingly americans are willing
to accept a vaccine as a way forward
a poll released today suggests that 80
percent say they're willing to get
vaccinated
though half of that group says they
prefer to wait a little while longer
just to be sure it's safe donna
all right jackson prosco in washington
thanks it's official president-elect joe
biden will take office
in january today the 538 members of the
u.s
electoral college formally cast their
votes in what is a bit of a bewildering
process
president trump is still refusing to
concede but it's clear biden won
306 electoral college votes trump won
232
it takes 270 to win by law the meeting
of the electoral college must take place
today their ballots must arrive in
washington by december 23rd
and on january 6 the ballots will be
counted during a joint session of the
house and senate
joe biden will be inaugurated as the
46th president of the united states on
january 20th
and late today president donald trump
tweeted that u.s attorney general
william barr has resigned and will leave
the job just before christmas
barr has been one of trump's most
steadfast supporters
aetna erupts ahead of fiery night in
sicily
a dramatic rescue in australia after a
major storm whipped up
all this sea foam onto a popular beach
it engulfed a dog her owner ran into the
foam and
managed to find the dog and pluck her
out southeastern queensland and
northeastern new south wales are being
battered by heavy rainfall king tides
and
flash flooding and in italy mount
etna is at it again launching plumes of
ash and lava into the sky
mount aetna lit up the night sky over
sicily on sunday
it is europe's most active volcano some
ash did fall on nearby villages but
there's no risk to anyone's lives from
this latest eruption
a magnitude 2.7 earthquake was recorded
on the mountain before this and there
have been more than
a dozen aftershocks
next delivering hope without forgetting
we still have months to go
when 2020 started we had no idea what
we'd be wishing for almost 12 months
later
no idea how life would change and that a
virus would infect every country in the
world
now our collective wish is simple we
wish life would get back to normal
and today canada took the first steps
today the first real ray of light of
2020 appeared
a tiny vial a precious vaccine a promise
that one day
the pandemic will end i'm so grateful
to be the first personal support worker
to take this vaccine
we have been waiting for this for so
long the first vaccinations in canada
are injecting hope
into our winter of despair make no
mistake
there's a long road ahead of us but what
this represents
is hope finally the virus that has
infected every aspect of our lives
has been outsmarted public health
doctors have reason to rejoice
bc's dr bonnie henry even did a happy
dance
scientists collaborated to crack the
viruses code in record time
producing a safe and effective way to
inoculate us
against it putting kovid 19 on the
defensive
not us here we are in december
and we actually have a vaccine against
that new virus
being administered you know not even
within the space of a full year
to my mind that is unbelievable and it
is a remarkable achievement of science
but the agony is not over this image
captures it a calgary doctor on his
knees
head in his hands calling another family
to tell them the bad news
covet 19 is still killing canadians by
the hundreds
often they die alone or with a doctor or
nurse with them
the relief of the first vaccines is
tempered by the staggering losses of
those who had no way to fight the virus
today manitoba's chief nursing officer
read a letter sent
by a 13 year old boy imagine the
suffering
and terror knowing you or your loved
ones might not live
or play in the park or breathe without a
machine
think about the big picture and we will
get through this
together we are still facing a long cold
winter
it will be essential in the months ahead
to do all we can to limit the spread of
the virus
but today with these first vaccines at
least we know
healing is coming
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is the sunset over
the crow's nest river near
lundbreck falls alberta there are
beautiful spots all over canada please
email us yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye